bonjour vous avez ce qu'il vous faut
comme discours aujourd'hui
ça tombe bien c'est le dernier jour à
partir de demain y en a plus qu'un
sannois cendres et c'est celui de
françois alors profitez-en
à partir de demain nous sommes tous
rassemblés dans le même discours celui
que porte françois pour nous devant les
français
françois fillon inventé le théorème de
la primaire très franchement mon cher
françois je ne connaissais pas mais je
les bienfaits trace sa route et ne te
laisse pas ta route tracée par les
autres tu nous a montré ton chemin
difficile au début tu as tracée avec
détermination et conviction et tu as
obtenu le soutien massif des électeurs
de droite mais aussi les électeurs du
centre
franchement vous pouvez être fiers de
vous on peut être fiers de nous
c'était quand même pas évident on a déjà
joué dans le passé entre l'éthique de
conviction et l'éthique de
responsabilité et nous arrête avec la
conviction
le reportage sur la responsabilité et
réciproquement
l'un on a fait une vraie campagne de
conviction
chacun défendu ses idées et maintenant
globalement nous assumons l'éthique de
responsabilité
c'est le respect de la démocratie le
résultat est incontestable et tous ceux
qui comme nous ont l'adn démocratiques
sont aujourd'hui rassemblés derrière
françois pour la france je pense que
dans une démarche collective
le courage c'est la loyauté
je ne vois pas de courage dans la
dissidence
je vois plutôt une faute et je vois un
mensonge
au fond la dissidence cache la solitude
derrière l'ambition nous nous portons un
rassemblement que nous avons
collectivement construit et que nos
électeurs ont massivement approuvé
c'est pour ça que nous sommes rassemblés
la droite et le centre
dans ce
deuxième round de campagne électorale
qui sera évidemment pour le pays décisif
je veux adresser un message de respect
et d'affection pour alain juppé et pour
nicolas sarkozy et pour tous ceux qui se
sont engagés dans ce débat qui nous a
permis aujourd'hui d'être rassemblés
grâce aux efforts des uns et des autres
et notamment à la qualité de
l'organisation de ce débat interne
nous sommes naturellement qu'une partie
de l'électorat de françois chast
électorat est beaucoup plus large
mais nous en sommes le visage le plus
observé le plus étudié et donc nous
avons une responsabilité particulière
nos humeurs peuvent être des erreurs
nous sommes observés scruter et nous
sommes ce visage d'un électorat qui doit
être déterminée mobilisés mais
fondamentalement responsable
dans ce contexte la mesure on la gravité
de la situation nous sommes pas dans une
compétition dans un match de foot on va
célébrer un vainqueur et que l'on va
verser quelques larmes
dans le camp des perdants non nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans un monde très
dangereux depuis que je fais de la
politique depuis que je m'intéresse aux
affaires du monde en politique étrangère
notamment je n'ai jamais vu la situation
internationale aussi dégradée quand vous
regardez ce qui se passe en mer de chine
en asie
nos inquiétudes sont fortes on est
contents de vendre des sous-marins aux
australiens mais vous croyez que si les
australiens ils achètent des sous-marins
c'est qu'ils sont tranquilles de la
situation tout autour d'eux quand on
voit l'armement aujourd'hui monté
nous sommes fiers d'avoir une industrie
de l'armement puissante mais on voit que
cet armement aujourd'hui révèle et
dangerosité qui arrive dans le monde
quand on voit tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en russie où monsieur
poutine va souvent à l'extérieur
chercher les satisfactions qu'il ne peut
pas donner à son peuple à l'intérieur et
on voit le nationalisme se développer
avec des tensions internes fortes mais
en même temps une mobilisation extérieur
quelque peu belliqueuse
quand nous voyons l'iran aujourd'hui
avec ses nouvelles ambitions
cette tension avec l'arabie saoudite
quand nous voyons tout ce que je passe
au levant et même temps nous gagnons des
positions au levant
que font les djihadistes que nous
chassons soit ils veulent revenir chez
nous soit ils s'en vont en libye à la
porte de ce pays de ce peuple frère
qu'est le peuple tunisien et qui est un
objectif majeur pour l'état islamique
pour porter atteinte à cette jeune
démocratie voisine à nos frontières
et si la tunisie fraîchit c est si
l'algérie était contaminée imaginez la
situation dans laquelle seraient
aujourd'hui et notre continent européen
et notre nation française quand on
regarde ce mot quand vous regardez ce
qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
et dans ces périodes récentes autour du
break site
quand vous voyez cette campagne
américaine
aujourd'hui nous verrons bien ce que
fera monsieur trempe mais il y avait
trois bonnes nouvelles en 2016 sur le
plan international je l'envoyais que
trois certes la cap 21 qui a été bien
vendu en france mais qui est quand même
un accord international de première
importance
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien et
puis il arrive et de goûter rsa l'onu
pour renforcer le multilatéral avec un
homme de qualité portugais européens
compétents et bien monsieur trompent ils
vont remettre en cause les deux accords
et cursi scruter l'action bilatérale de
l'onu dans ce mot
de dangereux l'élection présidentielle
française est quelque chose de grave
chers amis ce n'est pas un combat de
spectacle c'est l'avenir de nos enfants
jamais le monde n'a autant parlé de
guerre
jamais le monde ne s'y entend réarmer
jamais les états puissances n'ont
conduit autant de stratégies
individuelles et menaçante
dans ce contexte françois tu le sais
mieux que quiconque il nous faut un
président faure un président de sang
froid un président qui veut parler à
tout le monde
un président qui sait faire la
différence entre les colères et les
humeurs et les lignes stratégiques de
notre pays
dans ce contexte la de gravité on ne
peut pas donner les rênes de notre pays
à quelqu'un qui n'a pas la solidité la
profondeur de pensée
le calme de la sérénité c'est
franchement c'est pas pour nous c'est
pas pour nous c'est pas nous qu'il faut
penser dans ces circonstances si à nos
enfants à l'avenir de ce pays qui peut
très bien connaît des heures sombres car
le plus sombre n'est jamais éliminer
définitivement dans ce contexte là un
président faure un président comme
disait victor hugo dans ernani qu'ils
soient une force qui va et qui sait où
elle va cette fausse elle va on le sait
bien dans ton projet françois dans trois
directions principales
il faut débloquer l'économie française
je n'y reviens pas nous en avons
beaucoup parlé mais il est clair que la
grande ambition sociale donne notre
combat c'est l'emploi il ne peut y avoir
de rêve sociaux de vision sociale tamby
sion social avec le chômage qui augmente
c'est l'emploi la première de ses
ambitions et c'est pour ça qu'il nous
faut libérer l'énergie entrepreneuriale
c'est pour ça qu'il nous faut mou
de dépenses publiques et plus
d'initiatives privées et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut soutenir toutes les
initiatives et notamment celle que tu
allé saluer des jeunes parce que
finalement une des rares bonnes
nouvelles de notre économie
ce sont tous ces jeunes créateurs en
france et ailleurs
tous ces jeunes ingénieurs qui valorise
notre formation et qui aujourd'hui sont
porteurs d'une valeur d'avenir pour le
pays
c'est à eux que nous devons faire
confiance à condition que nous soyons
capables de libérer leur énergie et de
faire confiance à leur caractère
débloquer l'économie française
évidemment mais deuxièmement refonder
cette société de valeurs qui doit être
la société française celles de
l'humanisme français avec laquelle nous
sommes tous engagés
ça a été dit ici j'avais très vite mais
non à la société des excuses non la
société de l'irresponsabilité dont la
société de l'anonymat nous voulons une
société vivante une société qui respecte
la personne
une société qui considère qu'il y a dans
la personne quelque chose de sacré qu'il
y a un an nous les choses qui sont plus
grandes que nous et c'est pour ça que
notre dignité doit être partout
respectée et c'est pour ça que nous
avons la vraie égalité légalité de la
dignité fondée sur notre responsabilité
nous pouvons bien nous comporter
nous pouvons mal nos portes et c'est
notre responsabilité et c'est cette
responsabilité qui est la source de
notre dignité
dans ce contexte là ces valeurs sont
importantes pour nous de la fraternité
de la cohésion de la responsabilité et
de l'engagement
et tout ceci avec des forte volonté y
compris sur la laïcité
nous sommes engagés dans un combat pour
la laïcité mais ça nous empêche pas
évidemment de dire que nous sommes
chrétiens pour ce fils leçon est que
dieu te fier de l'air
et ma foi les chemins de saint jacques
de compostelle va bien la roche de
solutré
on peut parler de nos idées de jeu mais
jamais jamais nous ne ferons de la
religion un projet politique ce n'est
pas dans la religion que nous trouvons
et sourd du comportement politique
nous y trouvons des choses comportement
personnel des valeurs qui nous
conduisent mais qui ne doivent pas
conduire la société c'est la république
qui conduit la société
c'est dans ces conditions là avec
respect des uns et des autres mais un
respect dans la première des valeurs
c'est d'être réciproque
je te respecte mais il faut que tu me
respectes y compris dans mon identité
la plus profonde notre humanisme chers
amis ce n'est pas un humanisme
conservateur quand on est attaché à la
vraie valeur à la valeur de la personne
de ce qu'il ya de grandes en la personne
à sa responsabilité à sa dignité
on n'a pas peur du changement on n'a pas
peur des évolutions de société
on est attaché à la protection de la
personne
notre humanisme n'a rien de
conservateurs c'est un humanisme de
mouvement c'est un humaniste de création
c'est un humaniste qui permet le
dépassement c'est pour ça que c'est un
humanisme ouvert et donc nous avons là
vraiment de quoi assumer ce que
proposait alain juppé que nous pouvons
retrouver les uns et les autres dans
cette identité heureuse qui a un moment
faut bien sûr c'est une perspective
mais au fond de se dire que cet
humaniste vue-là il est fait pour nous
donner de la joie de vivre de la joie
d'être ensemble et najwa d'assumer notre
dignité d'homme développer l'économie
refonder la société de valeurs mais
aussi reconstruire la france puissance
de paix je termine par ce point parce
que nous devons repenser complètement
notre diplomatie
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans une
situation où on a une politique
étrangère éparpillés moi je suis
d'accord avec françois fillon
quand il propose le dialogue avec la
dîmière poutine
il n'y aura pas de solution au liban
sans la russie il n'y aura pas de
solution
évidemment avec un grand nombre de
puissance et ça ne veut pas dire qu'on
s'aligne
mais ça veut dire naturellement tournées
se payer la politique étrangère de la
france l'indépendance l'indépendance
nationale qui permet de parler à tout le
monde c'est cette indépendance là qui
fait qu'on est l'ennemi de personne mais
qu'on a nos convictions
on a nos stratégies mais cette
conviction ses stratégies elle est
fondée sur une ambition sur un mot un
mot qu'on entend très peu fière
j'assistais aux voeux du président la
république au corps diplomatique j'ai
très peu entendu le mot le mot clé de
notre politique étrangère
le mont le plus important pour nos
enfants le monde qu'elle nous devons en
permanence pensé c'est le mot simple
mais c'est le mot de paix si nous
voulons la puissance c'est pour la paix
c'est pas pour la guerre
si nous voulons une armée puissante si
nous voulons une dissuasion sûre veut 2%
du budget pour notre défense c'est pour
être capable de protéger le peuple
français et non pas pour être des vins
en guerre ici ou là pour être capables
de nous défendre
pouvoir faire peur à nos ennemis mais
parce que nous portons des valeurs de
paix et ses valeurs de paix nous pouvons
les conquérir passe à notre indépendance
capable de nous donner la force du
dialogue
c'est cette orientation là que nous
devons prendre aujourd'hui dans le monde
la france sur tous les grands foyers de
crise doit être mobilisée avec la
volonté de sa puissance mais une
puissance tu ne veux pas belliqueuses
mais qui se veut pacifique
si je crois pour cela qu'il ya
aujourd'hui à repenser le modèle
français de politique étrangère c'est
pour ça que je trouve que dans la ligne
qui nous est proposée par françois
fillon dans ce qu'il a construit
sédimenter avec les français partout il
y as pour nous cet honneur de retrouver
les forces de la france cet honneur de
retrouver le message de la france
cet honneur de redonner confiance et
courage aux français
nous sommes ici dans un conseil national
parce que ici évidemment à la veille des
élections législatives
nous aimons la politique mais n'oublions
jamais que ce que nous préférons c'est
la france
[Applaudissements]